na gta mégots bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on
vient de le dire l'algérie est l'un des
trois pays d'afrique les plus touchés
par le cos vite 19 un taux de mortalité
élevé près de 12% 1 275 morts depuis le
début est ce que vous confirmez
ces chiffres tout d'abord au fait
bonjour tout le monde franchement le
concernant les statistiques je n'ai pas
les chiffres exacts nous on est sur le
terrain
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que c'est
vrai qu'il y avait une mortalité
importante au départ et je sais pas est
ce que c est ce qu on peut dire que
c'est une mortalité importante du moment
où ou peut-être qu'on dépiste est pas
tous les cas tous les cas de kovy de
coronavirus maintenant c'est vrai que
moi j'exerce actuellement au niveau de
la réanimation qu'ovide au chu de blida
au départ on avait les tests on avait
les tests pcr
on avait que ça ait rapidement avec
l'affluence des patients ou pas dire le
l'institut pasteur et est rapidement
dépassé par le par le nombre de tests à
faire
récemment on en a eu on a eu des tests
rapides de dépistage de il me semble et
je pense qu'à partir de là on peut peut
être dépisté plus de patients et même le
personnel soignant carrément et et
peut-être qu'on verra une différence sur
ce taux de mortalité
je l'espère en tout cas alors vous venez
de le dire vous êtes à blida vous
travaillez à au service de réanimation
bidasses est l'épicentre de cette
épidémie
quelle est la situation sanitaire
actuellement l'or actuellement c'est
vrai qu'au départ on était on était un
petit peu désorganisé là on va une
organisation qui arrive à dire de la
part de tout le personnel
il ya eu une mise en place de beaucoup
de matériels au niveau de notre centre
est et là je ne sais pas peut-être que
les équipes sont mieux rodés à la
routine de prise en charge des malades
qu'ovide plus le matériel on en reçoit
quotidiennement et à beaucoup de
personnes qui aident aussi on reçoit
beaucoup de dans les rues je les
remercie d'ailleurs peut-être qu'il ya
eu la pression je pense elle est pareil
sur les 15 équipes soignantes
mais le fait d'être ou peut-être mieux
organisés à apaiser un petit peu les
esprits on travaille plus sereinement et
actuellement concernant les influences
nous on est sur le terrain
l'affluence des malades on a un
sentiment de même d'une petite accalmie
actuellement c'est à dire le nombre de
cas qu'on recevait au départ par
dizaines ou par vingtaines où ça
commence à diminuer maintenant est-ce
que c'est réel j'ai pas les chiffres
est ce que c'est juste une impression ou
ses réels on espère que ce soit réelle
mais tout de même reçu leurs prix
ensuite chiffres en algérie a pris alors
l'appréhension est toujours présente
leur centre d'art dont le nombre de
victimes que ce soit les contaminés ou
les morts est ce que il ya un problème
de recensement est ce qu'on les
estimations exact ou pas franchement jeu
franchement pour les ce que j'avais dit
au départ pour les statistiques je n'ai
pas les chiffres exacts effectivement
n'avait une mortalité assez importante
au départ les chiffres franchement je
n'ai pas de deux chiffres et je ne peux
rien je ne peux rien dire sur cela on
sait que le gouvernement a pris des
mesures notamment la distance
distanciation sociale est ce que les
algériens sont voile en état d' alerte
est ce qu'ils prennent leurs précautions
dans la rue es qu'ils restent confinés
chez eux
alors effectivement c'est après appris
la prise de ces mesures par parent par
le gouvernement au départ il y avait il
y avait quand même c'est à dire les gens
n'appliquaient pas vraiment ce
confinement d'une manière drastique
mais franchement ces derniers temps on a
l'impression que les gens adhèrent
franchement aux mesures de confinement
et peut-être au nom s'est passé juste
des justes des constatations peut-être
que cette petite accalmie qu'on ressent
c'est peut-être les premiers résultats
du confinement se dire les gens adhèrent
franchement ces derniers temps et
j'espère qu'ils vont poursuivre comme ça
on pourra nous gérer les quelques cas
qu'on reçoit aux urgences tranquillement
dernière question c'est que l'algérie a
adopté le 23 mars un protocole de
traitement basé sur la chloroquine il
est ce que vous en savez plus sur les
premiers résultats est ce que c'est la
bonne voie selon vo alors est ce que
c'est la bonne voie franchement on n'en
sait rien parce que vous savez très bien
ça n'a pas été validé ça n'a pas été
donc mais mais ça reste pour le moment
pour cette épidémie c'est ce protocole
reste là je pense le seul espoir et nous
dans notre service on l'a adopté dès le
départ et maintenant c'est vrai qu'on a
eu des malades qui sont guéris qui était
sous chloroquine et ou qui sont sortis
maintenant est-ce que c'est l'évolution
naturelle de la maladie où c'est le et
c'est le médicament je pense que
franchement je ne peux pas se prononcer
sur ça on sait pas ce que c'est
l'évolution naturelle de la maladie de
l'infection ou alors c'est l'effet réel
de la chloroquine de toute façon nous on
a adopté parce que quand même c'est une
molécule qui a acquis et qui a prouvé
sur sa stabilité auparavant et qui a été
très et qui était utilisée même chez les
sujets sains à titre préventif pour
certaines pathologies ou même pour se
traiter certaines maladies de système
donc nous on a adopté on va voir les
résultats on verra bien très bien en
tout cas merci beaucoup
najet d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste réanimatrice à blida en
algérie